thank you for joining us America Laci is
with us in South Bend Indiana
hi Lacey how are you hi I'm good my
question and I want to know how to
convince my boyfriend that buying a
truck is not a good buy which he's
already bought it a year ago but he
thinks just because he can make the
payment he can afford it I need to
figure out how to convince him otherwise
hold it
24th what's he do for a living
he is alignment okay well here's the
thing you need to keep in mind most of
us the statistics tell us that our
income and our ability to build wealth
will be within 10% of the average of our
closest 10 friends so whoever he's
running around with is telling him he's
a genius and they're all broke people
you follow me yeah and so on that that's
the thing you have to think about now it
doesn't there's nothing wrong with
anything you've told me about him
you know he's probably making pretty
decent money and he probably works his
butt off yes yeah
and the problem is though that the
people he's running around with are not
financial geniuses they work they work
hard and they spend all their money they
have nothing even though they make good
money and that's the that's the track
that he's on because anytime you say I
can afford it because you have payments
what that means is that you don't
understand how to build wealth because I
can afford it doesn't mean I have
payments I can afford it when rich
people say that it means they bought it
and paid for it as long as you have
payments you're giving away your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
your income okay so how do I convince
him well number one you can't convince
you can't make anybody decide to believe
something and so if he's not open to the
discussion then he's not going to be
convinced
but if he saw if he really is interested
in building wealth if he's interested in
becoming wealthy over time then he needs
to study that and as he studies that
real quickly he's going to understand
that you know wealthy people don't have
car payments and they're and it's not
that they got rid of car payments when
they were wealthy it's that they became
wealthy when they got rid of car
payments because here's the deal here's
an example if you don't write this one
down that will help you okay the average
car payment in America is four hundred
and eighty six dollars over eighty four
months okay if you were to invest that
amount of money from age 25 to age 65
instead of keeping a car payment your
whole life with the philosophy of oh I
can afford the payment so I can afford
it if instead of having that philosophy
you didn't ever have a car payment again
and you paid cash for your cars and you
invested that amount of money you follow
me yes you'd have five point six million
dollars that's what car payments cost
you five point six million dollars so
most people if they just if they did one
thing only and that was never have a car
payment again and invested a car payment
every month in an investment would be
multi millionaires with what most people
spend on car payments if they just put
that amount only if that was their only
financial move see that's how powerful
this is this idea of not having payments
great and so it's it's it's not just a
million it's millions of dollars so that
that car that he's driving that truck
that he's driving is a five million
dollar truck that's freaking expensive
it's actually not that it's actually not
that truck it's that truck and every
truck he buys from now until age
sixty-five that keeps him in card debt
because he believes that payments are
okay see when I saw that
now I'm not real smart but when I saw
that I said payments aren't okay anymore
right now again he may see that and go
well I Drive and if that's what he's
going to do honey he ain't marriage
material okay if he's not willing to
learn and grow and be smarter than he is
now if my wife had my lord if I the 24
year old Dave Ramsey you wouldn't even
want to meet him he was awful you know
if one of my daughters had wanted to go
out with a 22 year old version of Dave
Ramsey I wouldn't let him but the good
news but the good news is I didn't quit
there I started out redneck hillbilly
without a doubt still am in a lot of
ways and I'm proud of that
but but but I didn't quit learning and I
didn't get stuck and so if he stuck on
this if he stuck on stupid then you you
know he ain't marriage material you
follow me yes so hopefully he's willing
to learn and be convinced I'll send you
a copy for of a book for the two of you
to look at it's called the Total Money
Makeover and it covers some of the stuff
you and I were just talking about and
shows you how to do that but my
grandmother has a saying had a saying
Lacey she said those convinced against
their will are of the same opinion still
some people can't be convinced and then
you just have to decide you know how
much interaction you're going to have
with someone who can't be convinced and
I'm not going to try to convince some
people of some things I don't have time
I got I got plenty of people that want
to learn that I can help and you do too